moment of the sexual experience we'll
ask the young lady who's your daddy this
should be remixed if officer akimov is
watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james david
manning
[Music]
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth to reverence the word of god to
trust it to preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
george bush singer and george bush jr
have been penetrated by at least 100 men
in their anus area a hundred thousand
two hundred thousand strong i didn't do
it that's not my problem oh i got down
on my knees
i didn't do it but i was tempted
sounds like quite an evening
and loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done except they've
done it we've seen them
that certainly seems to be a story that
has been missed
[Music]
to love each other's semen how do you
know that it flavors the coffee gays
tend to love each other's semen
[Music]
each other's semen how do you know that
it flavors the coffee gays tend to love
each other as semen
[Music]
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of live
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of life
and we will be
men
mexico
[Music]
who's your daddy
well welcome everybody we are in day who
the hell knows at this point of the
johnny depp amber heard
defamation trial we're in a short break
right now and they'll be resuming
momentarily today we're hearing
testimony from dr shannon curry who's a
forensic psychologist and
being asked any number of different
questions about johnny depp and
different things and it is very very
interesting this trial is sort of a
combination of so many different things
it is celebrity disaster porn for sure
it's also about extreme privilege it's
about bizarre lawyering
uh it's about a lot of different things
and uh it is also about domestic
violence and abuse
um so we are standing by for the
resumption of that and i really
appreciate everybody joining me
my favorite moment of the trial so far
was yesterday when the butler was being
interviewed
and amber heard's attorney
objected to his own question
and everybody looked surprised and it
was bizarre now technically he was
objecting to the to the to the answer
but um
it was very weird he i mean he was in a
sense objecting to it to the question in
that it was what it was elicited by his
question this is bizarre check this out
interaction with debbie lloyd
when you're in the house correct yes
briefly
okay
and isn't it true that in the entire
time you were there
you were not informed as to
what caused damage to mr depp's hand on
finger on march 8th objection hearsay
i'm asking what he wasn't told
i'll sustain the objection next question
this is the best you didn't know what
could cause damage to mr deff's hand
while you were there on march 8th
correct dr kepler told me
he sustained an injury on one of his
weight oh rejection here's hearsay
you asked the
question the judge goes
well but you asked the question it it's
it's a kafka-esque moment for sure let's
go back a little bit here they need an
injury on one of his feet oh rejection
here's hearsay
you asked the question okay
even the lawyer goes oh oh
he he seemed to not even realize that he
asked the question that he was objecting
to and then johnny depp's lawyer over
here unable to contain his laughter
okay he said he sustained an injury to
his finger yes what a bizarre moment uh
very very strange so
just just a bizarre
bizarre in every in every way i don't
even know how else to describe it you
could call it cringy you could call it
comedy uh i don't know
couple of other things here um oh thank
you to margot cabot and jen here for the
twitch prime subscriptions i appreciate
that also thank you too i don't want to
miss anybody
thanks to kevin gouldy who just gifted a
subscription on my website
joinpakman.com
and evan porter gets that subscription i
appreciate that
super chat bay photo says did you see
sir hassan got coved i did
i mean you know i hope that he's
relatively symptom-free i don't know
much about it uh so many so many people
have had it at this point uh we wish him
the best of course
uh on c-span i believe this was earlier
today a guy called in and he didn't like
that there was a black woman and a
chinese guy on tv giving political
opinions they were they were
waxing nostalgic about the old days
where you would not see minorities on tv
listen to this bizarre moment current
things here in america that's going on
particularly
in the press
and the politics of america
i want to know
if uh
we could cut out some of this
if we could cut out some of these uh
these liberal things that are going on
in america just like in on the tv now
we have two minorities and i'm not
giving you minorities
the coffee cup pause
is just perfect
let's check out the coffee cup action
here
we have two minorities and i'm not
giving you minorities i made it three
years caller this that's that shouldn't
be a factor in the vic that we invite to
our program which we did invite so
what's your question or comment for them
please when i was a little boy listen
i'm 83 years old when i was a little boy
the colored people here okay we're gonna
stop it there let's go to nancy all
right
right
in fact i'm gonna be covering this
tomorrow i'm realizing
i can i can come up with a better title
it's not c span caller
furious that minorities get to have
opinions it's c span caller furious that
colored get to have opinions
uh so we'll update that really really
bizarre stuff i mean this is um
to call it retrograde
is uh probably uh not not not strong
enough okay we're standing by for the
resumption of the trial they're dealing
with some kind of evidentiary related
element there i want to say thank you to
adam gingrich adam just gifted a
subscription on our website
joinpacman.com
that one goes to kristin johnston
kristin congrat
kristen congratulations you get a
membership
adam gingrich also gifting an additional
membership that's number five today and
that one goes to adam johnson if you
want a free membership from me
go to davidpakman.com free membership
fill out the short form there are
currently
689 people waiting for free memberships
be like santa deliver
someone a gift you can gift a membership
at joinpackman.com by checking that this
is a gift box
and it is quite a box indeed
quite a box indeed um i do have some
other things to look at but let's maybe
wait until the next break because they
do seem imminently
uh going to resume here i have a couple
of new things on my soundboard in terms
of songs
we we tried this out yesterday at the
end of the republican pennsylvania
senate debate the imperial march seems
fitting for when we have just evil on
our screen so i now have that on my
soundboard
[Music]
so i think that that's a pretty good one
um and then here's another one that i
think might be good it's the seinfeld
theme let me see like for example we
could overlay it over like trump talking
about toilets
let's see here
um
like let's see if it would work okay so
let's let's just try and i'm gonna let
me see i might need to adjust the mix
uh
let's see
might need to go lower okay let's try it
so epa is looking at that very strongly
okay anyway so that's the concept i
think it's pretty good
um it may it may work for us
in future situations uh
oh and then i also now do have an entire
bathroom section as well where we
previously only had this clip people are
flushing toilets 10 times 15 times but
now we can add all of the following i
got gas
one time two times five times ten times
no water you can do that other thing
normally all right the third element of
the bathroom and i won't talk about the
third element of the bathroom okay
so the the sound board is really getting
very very packed and i i appreciate
everybody's contributions thanks to
christopher mcinnis christopher just
gifted a membership on my website that's
number six today and that membership
goes to the next person in line shalina
webster shalena webster there are
currently
690 people waiting for gifted
memberships i encourage you to get one
for yourself or gift one
johnny minogue dropping in a super chat
says enjoying at lunch my bag of mangoes
only six dollars last week at whole
foods you know i know you're joking
johnny but i oh and thank you to
engineer for the five gifted twitch subs
i appreciate that i know someone loosely
it's it's not someone i've ever it's not
a personal contact but it's like through
someone i know
who once was on a fruit and nut only
diet and sometimes like they would have
a dozen pears for lunch
uh once they had six persimmons for is
it six persimmons or is is persimmon
already plural like deer anyway they had
six persimmon fruits
for dinner
um
it was bizarre
it was an absolutely bizarre thing and
you know one of the things i my view on
all of this nutrition stuff is
do whatever the hell you want like
it's sort of like with exercise right if
you prefer running and you prefer
crossfit and you prefer hanging upside
down and you prefer um
you know only working out your wrists i
don't care do do whatever the hell you
want just don't bother other people with
it
and similarly when it comes to diets you
know it's like
fruit and nuts only have a party i don't
care uh whatever right dairy free soy
free vegan vegetarian pe
meat only
do whatever the hell you want just just
leave me out of it you know what i mean
it's like i don't i just don't care
um
it's uh for for you to figure out what
you want
um okay
let's continue here i wanna say thanks
to colin hughes colin just signed up at
joinpackman.com welcome colin great to
have you here
in the minutes we have left until this
receipt resumes
let's um
let's listen to a couple of voicemails
okay a couple of voicemails here let me
see what i've got
hello there god the great grandkids
asked me about politics and i didn't
know that they had the little recorder
in their pocket
and they asked me grandpa how do you
know which one you're going to vote for
and i i was telling them that all
politicians
regardless of parties they're all lying
cheating thieving bastards well it
sounds like an instructive conversation
with the was it grandkids or great
grandkids because he seemed to say both
which is a little weird
hello david this is evan in colorado
again i uh just left you a voicemail um
and i am as you say shot out of a cannon
today so i had two more things that i
thought about um in between i started
listening to
another skeptical individual on youtube
seth andrews i don't know if you've
heard of them
uh okay this goes three minutes
and then cuts off and i can tell from
the transcript they never get to the
question it's three minutes of lead up
so with per with permission
uh i'm gonna go ahead and skip the rest
of it
hey david um this is cody i'm from
atlanta hi
um
i was just thinking about something man
i just wanted to share it and uh
um
and we lost it all right it seems like
we're back here
all right we're ready for the jury then
bringing the jury in
we'll get the audio and everything all
squared away for you guys don't worry
it's all fine are there any coupon codes
you can use yes there's oh i have the we
have sad trump up there for non-trump
streams
i actually find that the code
obama is better see we now switched it
to obama obama that there are plenty of
codes you can always use whatever code
you want that's not a imag i'm as
agnostic on coupon codes as i am about
diets that other people choose it's it's
fine
i do wonder if we should have a co like
a code like grumpy if we were to have a
johnny depp trial related coupon code
what could it be grumpy seems like a
fair one but if somebody has a better
suggestion i'll gladly set that up
is there anything better than grumpy
hearsay
grumpy or here's hearsay are the only
ones i could really think of
the only problem with grumpy is
is it i e or y
hearsay might be the right one
very serious man says they'd be in for a
grumpy
uh we call officer melissa signs by
deposition designation
and just so the jury is aware uh for the
first hour or so what you'll hear is
questioning by ms heard's counsel uh it
will then shift to questioning by mr
depp's council okay thank you this
should be interesting
please state your name and your business
address
yes um officer melissa science
1546 west martin luther king jr
boulevard los angeles oh boy is this
recorded testimony
i am a police officer
okay and how long have you been a police
officer
uh going on 12 years dear god when
what year did you begin
as a police officer
2009
and was that with the lapd
yes it was
did you have any law enforcement
experience prior to coming to the lapd
in july of 2009
no i did not
as of may 21 2016 what was your rank
can you repeat the date
may 21st 2016.
i was a training officer
and was that a p3
correct
and as a training officer were you
considered a field training officer
right
and for how long a period of time had
you been a training officer
as of may 21 2016
approximately
i believe four months
all right so our new code is hearsay for
reasons of spelling ease became a
training officer at the lapd
i don't recall
when did you start training officer
hadden
i i don't recall the exact month
do you have an approximant
uh if the incident was in may that it's
going to be within
two months of may before or after
so are you suggesting that you may not
have started training officer hadden
until two months after the may 21 2016
incident so he wasn't there
no i'm not
was it
two months or less from the time you
started training officer hadden before
the may 21 2016 incident
yes so
i have a probationer for two months
so may could have been the second month
i had him or the first month i had him
but you don't recall as you said here
today how long you had been training
officer hadden as of the may
21st 2016 incident all right
what does central division i'm going to
find the video feed standby hey
encompass downtown los angeles
in may of 2016
what shift were you on
i was working nights
and and what
night shift entail what was the time
from when to win
i don't see an nbc feed oh cbs standby 6
45 p.m
to 6 45 a.m
and how many days a week would you work
the chef
usually three days a week
typically what was the range they don't
seem to have the video oh here it is
in may 2016 in central division
all right i don't recall
i i mean are we talking less than five
more than 10 more than 25
[Music]
there would be at least five units
how high over that i i wouldn't know
that every again every night is
different the city pulls from different
divisions if there's special events
going on so it's constantly changing
[Music]
okay
um
but
it's usually at least five and maybe
somewhere between five and ten if
there's not a special event would that
be a fair estimate
[Music]
correct
what was the process for checking out
equipment in may
2016
after roll call
we would walk to the window and
give them our name and serial number and
then would present us with
equipment for the shift
and what equipment were you given
in may 2016
after roll call
i don't recall
you don't recall any of the equipment
you were you checked out in may of 2016
after roll call
i don't remember that specific
day that i checked out equipment i can
tell you what i typically check out if
that's what you'd like
all right let's start there
i usually check out a police vehicle
a taser
a less lethal beanbag shotgun
and a regular shotgun
[Music]
anything else
no nothing else
do you check out body worn video
equipment
yes if you were trained
in body worn video then yes you would
check that out
all right were you trained in body worn
video equipment
i was not
have you ever been assigned
body worn video equipment
[Music]
yes i have when
i don't remember the specific date
[Music]
what is your best estimate
if i had to guess it would probably be
june of 2016.
[Music]
why do you think it was june of 2016
that you
first were assigned to body-worn video
equipment
because that's
the time frame that i remember
having to use it it was new to me i
never used body one before
when did the lapd start issuing
body-worn equipment for central division
i don't know that date
when approximately
i don't know i couldn't give you a date
can you name any other officer that did
not have body worn equipment that was on
your shift at any time
between november 2015 and june 2016
other than you
i cannot oh have you had more than one
equipment
body worn camera is that what you're
asking yes
i have had two
one in central division
and now weird uh
southwest division where it currently am
the camera stays at their respective
divisions
while you were at central division did
you ever get assigned more than one body
worn video camera
not to my knowledge
so to the best of your knowledge you had
the same body worn video camera
throughout the time that you were at
central division is that correct
correct
do you have a recollection
of at any time while you were at central
division
your body worn video camera
not working
so you couldn't turn it on during an
incident
i do not recall that
what tools were available to you in may
of 2016 for investigating calls
answering and investigating
can you specify what you mean by tools
well
did you have a notebook for example
yes we carry phil officers notebooks
and
did you have your own field officer
notebook
yes i should describe what your field
officer notebook looked like in may of
2016.
it's a small
just paper pad that we keep in our
pockets to write on
and do you carry a pencil or a pen with
it so that you can take them out during
a call and take notes
i do
what do you do with your notebooks once
you have filled them
you can turn them into the kit room and
they can store them
is that what you have done
i have
i have my same officers filled uh field
officers notebook in my locker
started
uh no i thought i've had several
different ones but i usually keep them
in my locker
so
very suspicious for the field officers
notebook that you had in may of 2016
that would be in your lacquer
it should be yes
how many field officer notebooks have
you filmed since you've been a police
officer
not many probably less than
less than five
fewer than five do you recall how many
roughly how many pages are in each field
officer notebook
i
no i don't recall
did you have access to dart
i don't i don't recall what hours they
worked at central division
and what did dark stand for
i don't know the specific acronym but i
know it's the domestic violence
card
did you also have access to
uh
report types of reports incident reports
various forms diagrams things of that
nature in case you needed them
yes i did
and where were where were those kept
while you were on a shift
i'm talking about may 2016
i usually keep extra spare reports in my
bag and i also keep them in my vest
so when you answered calls in may of
2016
you had reports material in your vest
as you answered calls is that correct
yes
it's uh deposition exhibit number 14.
it's a multiple multiple-page document
i'm just asking her if she recognizes
this document
yes i do
okay
when is the last time you reviewed this
document
about a week ago
this is amber heard's attorney currently
asking the questions everybody
for this testimony
now
i asked you some questions about uh the
body worn video
are you aware
of
anyone
any other officer being assigned your
body worn
video under your serial number
i'm not aware
is there any chance that you could be
mistaken about when you were assigned
body worn video
no there's not
and why do you say that
because everything is recorded and
documented on evidence.com under my
serial number
evidence.com so if a supervisor wanted
to
enter the database under my serial
number
they could watch my videos and see
the specific date and time
my videos started to record
and when the date of my last video was
to this date
all right and
did you go back and look to see what
date you started
i did
what was the date that you were assigned
body worn video equipment in central
division
so the first day that i took out body
worn video was june 16th of 2016.
i'm going to show you this second page
of what has been marked as deposition
exhibit number one
it it has you summoned to attend and
give testimony at a deposition and also
to produce
certain documents do you recall this
being issued
yes i do
and here we go
the documents to be produced um
the first of those was
all video footage recorded by you
relating to any incident at 849 south
broadway los angeles california 90014
on may 21 2016
including all video footage relating to
incident number and it has the number on
may 21 2016.
did you conduct any type of search or or
any kind of uh
effort to see if you had any video
footage on may 21 2016 relating to this
incident the answer is no
i'm going to ask you to take did the
anyone at the lapd at any point
supervisors watch commanders commanders
anyone connected with the lapd
ever asked you
whether you had any video footage from
the incident of may 21 2016. no
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
number two here it says all documents
and or communications including without
limitation any notes memoranda reports
filings and or summaries relating to any
incident at 849 south broadway los
angeles california 9001 4 on may 21
2016.
are you aware of any documents or
communications
that would fit this description
no
now
officer signs you've had training
on domestic violence correct
could you tell me what that consists of
we received training in the police
academy
anywhere else did you have any other
type of domestic violence training other
than when you were in the place academy
other than my experience in the field
around with domestic violence no not
that i can recall
and
as of may of 2016
would you agree
that you had
answered
over 100 domestic violence calls
about yeah we yeah i go to yes i go to a
lot of domestic violence calls every day
okay
and you consider yourself to be a
specialist in domestic violence is that
accurate
i don't i don't understand the title
specialist i don't
consider myself specialist
in may of 2016
what was the police officer supposed to
do when the victim of a domestic
violence would not respond to questions
or cooperate with pursuing charges after
a call was placed and the police
officers had arrived
if an individual is uncooperative
we are to check the location to make
sure that the suspect isn't hiding
for the safety of the
potential victim
and offer a business card if they decide
to speak to us later in may of 2016 was
it your understanding that if you saw
evidence of injury
or property damage and disarray that you
were to file a report even if the victim
was not cooperating
correct
pretty sure he was remarked as exhibit
number eight
and this is uh this could get
interesting stated november
24 2018 it's to all department personnel
from the chief of police
domestic violence supplemental report
form
and it starts out with a domestic
violence supplement report form and it
has the number of it has been revised to
provide a more concise picture of the
history and needs of the victim for the
purpose of investigating the crime of
domestic violence
was this a document that you call
receiving at some point
yes
okay and do you understand what do you
have any understanding of why
this was supplemented in november 24
2014
how do you know
i'm going to ask you officer take a look
at what has been marked as exhibit
number nine
and it's called los angeles police
department domestic violence
supplemental report do you recognize
this document yes
okay and
what is your understanding what this
document is
it's a supplemental document that we
add to a police report for domestic
violence
and is this one of the reports that you
would carry in your vest
when you answered calls
yes
i'm going to ask you to take a look uh
if you if you can at the very left hand
column
where it has a number of different
uh categories here that has victim
shaking unresponsive crying scared angry
fearful
of why
these are included on this supplemental
domestic violence report
so i identified somebody's emotional
state during an investigation
and this is specifically with respect to
domestic violence correct correct
okay and then if you can turn over to
the crime scene section on the right
hand side
uh you'll notice that
there are some categories that include
location vandalized
ransacked
personal property damage furniture
disarray broken
what is your understanding of why those
categories are included in there for
making notations for domestic violence
supplemental report
to identify the crime scene at the time
of the incident
okay
and was it your understanding that these
items that they have on here may be
significant
in assisting having some serious audio
interference domestic violence and
improving and improving the case
right
and direct your attention specifically
to the evidence section
uh and it indicates witnesses present
during domestic violence
statements taken evidence collected
photos taken
on there what is your understanding of
the significance of this and from
collecting this information
it's significant to tell a story about
what happened at the
domestic violence incident
okay
and then if we can scroll down a little
bit further to additional questions
there's a series of those
including has suspect threatened to kill
you
do they possess firearms have they ever
attempted to smother strangle or
suffocate you
and things of that nature what is your
understanding of why you're supposed to
ask those questions
give you a background on the
relationship an idea of what
the victim and the suspect have been
through
okay thank you just just let me ask you
the question officer science you did not
fill out that supplemental report
when you responded on may 16 20 20 may
21 2016
to the broadway uh call correct with
amber
heard correct it did not meet criteria
and the question i asked was did you
fill out one of those forms
no i didn't know it did not mean
science i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as exhibit
number 10 and if i can direct your
attention to the top
it says domestic violence standards of
review and it has field notebook divider
domestic violence laws lapd form number
18.30.02 are you familiar with that
yes
it's it has case preparation it says
note the complainant's emotional and
physical condition do you see that yes i
do
and then ensure all evidence is gathered
and preserved eg bloody clothing damaged
phones property
you see that yes
and it also says ensure photographs are
taken of injuries or
lack of injury to complainant and
accused
and then suggests both the day or two
after what is your understanding of the
reasons for collecting this evidence
because these are fruits of a crime
i i'm sorry i didn't because these are
first of a crime if there's a crime this
is important to prove that a crime was
committed
and what do you mean by fruits of a
crime like mango cherries
if we're talking domestic violence
the location would be evident so if
there's
you know a house is a ransacked and that
should be noted in the report that would
be considered evidence
all right then we're going to go to the
second page here
and it has
ensure photographs are taken of seen and
damaged property e.g broken furniture
holes in wall damage
phones
phone card evidence of alcohol
consumption general disarray do you see
that
yes i did and what is your understanding
of why that would be important
same thing first of all
okay
and then it also says canvas location
and interview all witnesses
including children fresh complaint
witnesses neighbors and local law
enforcement do you see that
yes i did and what would be the reason
for canvassing the location and
interviewing all witnesses
that would be further evidence
all right and what is your understanding
of what fresh fresh complaint means
i
i wouldn't i couldn't tell you
okay
and then if we go down a little bit
further it also has complainant
questions
and it has
questions such as length and nature of
relationship but also prior incidents of
domestic violence reported and
unreported
uh and what form of violence or abuse
has taken do you see that yes they do
and how how what is your understanding
of why that would be important
because it gives us an idea on
background of the relationship
okay
and then we go to the next page
and we have a little bit more here
uh we have the
for everybody saying that depp's lawyers
don't get a chance here they they do
that's on the same recording
and that says how long the abuse has
been occurring any logs or diaries
is there a pattern of alcohol or
substance abuse what is your
understanding of why those would be
relevant
again because it gives us background on
what we're dealing with what type of
relationship this is
and may help with the proof of the uh
the crime
right
okay and then we have identify the
person who first saw the complaint after
the incident and it says in parentheses
fresh complaint witness so i'm kind of
guessing that must be the definition um
but why would it be important to
interview or identify the person who
first saw the complaint after the
incident
they probably have the best recollection
okay and also has identified the person
with whom the complainant first spoke
about the incident fresh complaint
witness what is your understanding of
why that would be important
same thing the best recollection
okay
and then we have
what have neighbors seen or heard
why would that be important
they would prove to us that there was an
incident if there was other people with
the same story as a victim
okay
and then we also
have did witness observe how physical
injury occurred why would that be
important
because that would tell us that
there was a crime that somebody got
injured
and then we have
statements by the complainant and or
accused after the incident why would
that be important
because we're getting our story from the
complaint so
what they say is everything with the
crime all right let's look at 12 for a
moment this is uh from this is exhibit
number 12. it's office of the chief of
police april 9 2002
uh and it's a domestic violence victim's
memo
and it says purposely this is this is
pretty tedious i'm with you guys to
provide specific information to victims
of domestic violence crimes
and then they go in to describe that
um
what is your understanding of
well let me go a little bit further
because i'm not trying to i'm just going
to try to move through this a little bit
quicker so it says to mitigate this
issue the department has
begun to use the victim information
notification every day vine pamphlet to
accomplish not only the domestic
violence information required
requirements under section 13 701 of the
california penal code but also to
provide information regarding the vine
program
did you did you have a copy of that
pamphlet was that something that was
given to you
yes
okay
and it was that something that you
typically provided then as it says you
should to victims of domestic violence
yes
what is your understanding of why you
were to provide the pamphlet
you understand the question
yes because it gives resources to the
victims domestic violence resources like
uh shelters and
uh phone numbers to provide help i'm
going to show you what has been worked
is exhibit number 11. do you recognize
this document
yes i do this is the vine
okay would you say vine is this the
pamphlet that we've been referred to
okay and it's your understanding that
you were supposed to be giving that
pamphlet to victims of domestic violence
on calls is that correct
correct did you provide a copy of this
pamphlet to amber heard
i did not i did not identify her as a
victim of domestic violence
is that the sole reason why you did not
give that to amber
heard yes we want to give them to the
victims of domestic violence i'm going
to ask you to take
this point in your honor
at this point your honor uh miss herd's
council is asking to move into evidence
and publish to the jury defendants
exhibit 730 and mr depp has no objection
all right 7 30 in evidence
it's quite a legal team here
this is what we call an element
okay
okay keep going
first page of exhibit number three it's
an incident recall
uh from
specifically may 21st 2016.
do you recognize this document
yes i do
and what please explain to me what what
it is
it's a summary of our radio call
all right and
how is this recorded
by dispatch
and
how is it communicated to you
a computer in our card
okay
so
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
the very beginning of this and start
well it starts out it obviously has an
incident number uh is this your
understanding of the incident recall
for the report to 849 south broadway
involving amber heard
yes
it starts out with 521
16 at 20 30 58 which is 8 30 58 or
almost 8 31
and it says incident initiated by such
and such
uh do you see that yes i do
okay
and the next thing that's communicated
is penthouse three pr received call from
victim's friend amber assaulted by
boyfriend pr refused to give further you
see that yes
now
when you were
out on the road did you see that right
away or did you have to look this up
later when it was you that was going to
respond
we review the calls as we're driving to
the to the call okay
then we have
at 5 21
20 37 which is 8 37 a duplicate call do
you see that i do
all right let's go down to 521-16
officer science can you go where i just
highlighted here
and it's it's uh
2057
which would be what time
857.
all right and it has
s-t-a-t colon a-s what does that mean
so
would that be
when you and officer hadn't arrived
at 849 south broadway
correct
and then it has the next entry is 521
2016 it has
21 22 57 so that would be
9 22
okay and it says
go ahead i'll have you read this what
does it say
matt
with vic
chuck loke
verified husband left slope
vic advice
verbal
okay go ahead into the next go ahead and
go into the next page or next line go
ahead dispute and refuse to give any
further info
issued
business card
who wrote
those two lines
i i don't recall
and
what did that mean to you
those two lines that you just read
it's a it's a disposition of what
happened at the call
okay can you can you tell me what that
means i mean just tell me in real
person's words what those words are
yeah that we met with the victim
we checked the location
uh
the husband wasn't there
and that the victim advised us that she
just had an argument and that
she wasn't going to give us any further
information
and because we didn't identify a crime
we issued her a business card
letting him know that she could reach
out to us later she changed her mind and
wanted to cooperate
okay
and at what point did you close this
incident
uh whatever it says on the screen uh
let's see 9 22 57
okay and what did incident closed mean
that we cleared from the location we're
complete
done
okay
now if we could go to page
bait stamp number 12
so for everybody asking why she's
wearing a mask by herself i think one
possibility is there's a bunch of people
in the room with her including
potentially police attorneys or whatever
else and this was you know at a time
when people were wearing masks that
would be my guess but i don't know
document in preparation for this
deposition is that correct yes i did
great
and if we can go down to
right here
that's
922 correct at the end of that
right
all right
and it says
242 d domestic violence what is that
it's uh it's a code for domestic
violence
and what does the 242-d mean
that's battery officer science when we
broke before the lunch break i had just
asked you about whether
you had believed that you were at
the penthouse on may 21st
2016 uh for 30 to 60 minutes do you
recall me asking that yes i do
and do you recall testifying that that's
what you thought was the time that you
an officer hadn't spent at the penthouse
on may 21st 2016. yes very cool
okay
and in fact
it was significantly less correct
correct
okay and in fact it was
uh you entered
from the elevator at 904 pm and went
back into the elevator at 9 19 for a
total of 15 total minutes correct
correct
okay and and
we've seen the video clips of you
getting on the elevator and getting off
and that's where those time stamps come
from now once you got off the elevator
at 904 pm
uh the first thing you did was listen
for some noise correct
correct
all right and then you
went around
uh
and checked out the outdoor courtyard to
see if anyone was outside do you recall
that yes i do
and you
saw that there was a woman in the gym
who was not related to the incident do
you recall that correct how did you know
the woman was not related to the
incident
because she seemed unfazed she was just
working out
did you speak with her
no i didn't
do you recall what she looked like
i don't
now
did you take any notes during the entire
15 minutes from when you got off the
elevator until when you got back on the
elevator
i did not
did officer hadden to your knowledge
not to my knowledge no okay did you uh
take pictures or record anything i did
not
so after you saw the woman in the gym
and and looked at the perimeter you went
back to the hall the hallway and you met
with
what you called
a white male who is generic do you
recall using that term
they asked me to describe him yes
and and you said generic correct
and what do you mean by generic
it didn't have any
uh identifying
uh
i don't know nothing that i could
remember he just i just remember a male
white
nothing out of the ordinary unremarkable
what color was his hair
i
don't even remember now
did he have facial hair a beard or a
mustache
i don't remember
do you recall how tall he was roughly
i don't remember anything about him did
you ask him his name
i don't recall
now the generic white male talked with
you do you recall that yes i do
and when you first saw amber heard she
was crying
red eyed and was not making eye contact
with you correct
correct
and you asked her a few questions and it
was quite clear that she did not want to
speak to the police is that correct
correct now amber heard was visibly
upset
so she would look down sometimes she
would look up at you when she spoke but
was back and forth correct
what was ever heard wearing that
mag i don't recall
what
hairstyle did amber heard have that
night
i don't recall
now
when was the first time you were asked
to provide details of the events of may
21 2016.
i don't recall
do you recall providing your testimony
at a deposition in
july of 2016.
is that the first time you were asked to
provide any details of what your
recollection was of the events of may 21
2016.
okay and that was roughly two months
later is that correct
correct
and how many shifts had you worked in
that two-month period
uh i'm not aware i don't know
how many calls had you answered in those
two months
i don't know that number
how many of those calls were domestic
violence calls in those two months
i don't know that number
and
if you
saw any signs of injury on amber heard
or even just damage to property
would you have been duty-bound to make a
report
correct
now
your
recollection is that there was no damage
to the the flat you searched the entire
flat and there was no damage broken
glass or anything out of the ordinary
would you agree
correct
did you
see anything did you observe anything
out of the ordinary during this
particular call that you answered at the
penthouse on may 21 2016.
i did not
when you left that call when you got
back into that elevator do you recall
what you were thinking
i remember being impressed by the the
penthouse how big and beautiful it was
yes
but anything else suspicious no nothing
okay
and just so we can stay on that for a
minute you did not
you had not heard of amber heard at the
time of this report right on may 21st
2016
correct
but you did know that johnny depp was an
actor correct
correct
and you didn't know that that was johnny
depp's penthouse when you reported that
correct
correct
but
you as you just said were impressed with
the penthouse would it be fair to say
you thought probably somebody who with
some wealth lived there
correct can you bring up plaintiff's
exhibit number 23
[Music]
very interesting
do you recognize this elevator at all
yes i do
what do you recall
that's the elevator from the location
okay
uh alex i'm going to ask you to go
to
21 19
40. and as you're moving that officer
science i'm going to ask you to take a
look at this and see if you can tell me
what you are saying to officer hadden
in this video clip
that's you is that correct
right and officer hadden do you
recognize
officer science did can you tell what
you were saying to officer hadden i
cannot does it look like you might have
said at the beginning that was crazy
i can't tell what i was saying
would you agree though that you were
quite animated in your discussion with
officer hedden
no i wouldn't agree
how would you describe your demeanor
[Music]
comfortably talking to my partner
all right i'm going to ask you to take a
look at plaintiff's exhibit number 17
and while alex is bringing that up
so your best recollection is that you
signed no injuries on amber heard
correct
correct
and your best recollection is you sign
death no property damage nothing in
disarray nothing out of the ordinary
correct
correct
and if you had seen either of those you
would have had to file a report we must
be building to something
officer science let me ask you this
question so
we've established that you
uh got off the elevator on the
level at 904 pm do you recall that
yes i do
do you recognize the person here
yes i do amber heard
okay
and do you see
any signs of injury
on amber's herd's face in this picture
i do not
is it your testimony
that you do not perceive this cheek to
be reflecting an injury on amber heard
correct no injury
to take a look at this section here
above the eyelid and now i think with
the uh i'm going to ask you to take a
look at that eyelid is it your
perception that that eyelid does not
reflect an injury
i'm sorry what was your answer
correct no injury
okay and then up above on the forehead
level where the redness is and it looks
like there's a couple of
bumps is it your perception that does
not reflect an injury
correct officer science i'm going to ask
you to look at what has been marked as
deposition exhibit number 18
close to the time that you alighted from
the elevator correct
please describe for me what you see in
this photograph
a striped carpet with discoloration on
the
right hand side of the photo and
what i perceive as i don't know if
that's a reflection
some sort of mark
now
you
believed and testified in fact that you
considered the hallways to be very well
lit that night correct
correct
did you see this
in the stains
no not that much
right do you
do you
would you agree that there are those are
reddish stains on the right side
correct
what does it look like from your
experience
like a stain like from a like a liquid
red wine
possibly
it could be yes
okay
but you don't recall seeing that in the
hallway after you got off the elevator
i do not
and you did not investigate this or take
any pictures or record anything about it
correct
correct
okay
now let's go to number 19.
do you recognize what is depicted in
exhibit number 19
yes it's our business card
and it has one a1 on the front of it
what is that that's our unit designation
and then it has had and a badge number
is that his badge number
that is his serial number okay serial
number thank you and it has your name
and is that your serial number correct
who who wrote this on the card
i don't recall
would it have been either you or officer
hadden
correct
do you recognize your handwriting
i i can't tell from this
no i think you indicated when you were
looking at the incident recall
and the cad summary
uh that a business card had been left do
you recall that yes i do
and why did you leave a business card
i advise uh amber heard that
she could contact us at any time if she
changed her mind and decided that she
wanted to
speak to us and cooperate
all right let's go to number 20.
do you recognize this
what's been depicted in this picture
yes i do it's the back of the business
card
all right
and it says
5 21 2016
and the time is 9 16 p.m
is that the time that the car
was written
correct
okay
and do you recognize the handwriting on
this side
that looks like my handwriting
okay
now it says radio call of dispute do you
see that
i do
um
did did you why didn't you put verbal
dispute
it didn't
verbal dispute just do it's the same
it's the same thing to me
and you have refused to report on here
correct correct
could you just read this next part that
you wrote on here
sure advice can call at later time it
changes mind because she was
uncooperative and didn't want to speak
to us
okay
now
why did you say if change is mined
because i was giving her the opportunity
to have a resource if she changed her
mind
but if amber heard had no injuries and
there was no evidence of any type of
physical
property issues
disarray breakage etc
um
then why would it matter if she changed
her mind
it's a courtesy that i
i choose to give
people when i go to calls
no there might have been something that
happened for which there wasn't physical
evidence and if she wanted to
communicate it she could i mean i had
not written a report and had taken no
notes correct
correct
but
if i'm understanding your earlier
testimony that if you saw evidence of
injury
or if you saw injury of
evidence of property damage even if the
victim did not cooperate
you would write a report correct
correct
and we'll go to number 21. officer
science this is just a uh picture do you
recognize you and officer hadden here
yes i do
okay
is the time stamp on here everything
about this is where 19
p.m 49 p.m does that compare with your
recollection of when you left
i don't recall what time i left i'm just
going based on the video that is in
front of you
okay
you have any reason to believe that's
incorrect
i don't
office science i'm going to ask you to
take a look at exhibit number 24.
can you recognize the person in this
photo yes amber heard
okay
do you perceive
uh there to be an injury or evidence of
injury on amber's face
in this fight
no i do not
uh
what is your
uh perception
of the redness on the cheek and the
eyelid and above the eyebrow
it's consistent with
she's fair skin her face is flush i'm
going to ask you to look at what have
been marked as exhibit number 25
do you recognize this as amber heard
yes do you see a red mark on amber
herd's
cheek and above her eyelid and above her
eyebrow on this picture
her face looks flush yes redness
okay and what is your perception
of
what that is caused by
like i said earlier it's consistent with
what i see in her crying
sorry but you don't think it's
consistent with a cell phone being
thrown at her
correct it does not look like an injury
caused from a cell phone
okay and why not
because it's consistent with somebody
crying her face is flushed this was
taken at on may 21st i'm going to ask
you to look at what happened marked as
exhibit number 26 it was to be
recognized this is amber
yes i do
science do you see
any redness on amber herd's cheek and
above her eyelid and we'll go with those
i do
and
what is your perception of what the
cause of those is those red marks
consistent with her crying her face is
flesh
and is it fair to say that you do not
believe that this reflects an injury
correct
and would it also be fair to say that
you
would not consider it sufficient to
investigate further
whether it's an injury
there's nothing that would stop me from
investigating i would continue to ask
her questions
and it's up to the victim if they want
to cooperate
but just so that we were clear here even
if the victim doesn't cooperate if you
see signs of injury you still
and i believe you testify to this
believe yourself duty bone to write a
report correct yes
but in your mind
you don't perceive this as to be
reflective of an injury is that correct
correct
and i'm going to ask you to take a look
at exhibit number 27. again do you
recognize this as amber heard
yesterday okay and
do you see what's with the cutoff
objections on the tape anybody
understand that
all right and then you have testified on
a number of these other pictures and on
this one as well that this is consistent
with crying
do you see any redness on amber's other
cheek
yes i do
is it the same or or similar to the
redness on the cheek on the right shape
based on this photo it looks
like one cheek is brighter than the
other
and but you also don't see any
uh swelling with that
correct i'm going to ask you to take a
look at what has been marked as exhibit
number 28.
do you recognize this as amber heard
yes
okay and do you see redness on the right
cheek and above the eye
yes i do
okay and
the
is it your perception
that this reflects any type of or could
reflect any type of injury
[Music]
no
why not
because my perception is it was
consistent with her crying
all right let's take this don't go to 29
i'm going to ask you the same questions
do you recognize this as amber heard
yes
and do you see any
redness in the right cheek and above the
eyelid
yes
okay and
is it your perception that these are not
indicative of injury
yes and and what is your reasoning
it's consistent with recrying
let's take this one down let's go to
number 30.
now
you testified
earlier that you
thoroughly searched the penthouse did
you recall that testimony
yes i do
okay
uh and
josh drew the gentleman that you called
the generic male
actually took you through and escorted
you through the
penthouse and the series of penthouses
correct
officer science did you or did you not
thoroughly search the penthouses on may
21st 2016.
we did search the pounds
okay and you used the term thoroughly
did you not
i don't recall
okay
do you feel like you conducted a
thorough search of the penthouses that
make yes i did i did a sweep of the
location for the suspect
okay and when you're talking about a
sweep of the location did you go through
every room
yes every room okay and was there anyone
escorting you through those rooms
yes the same mail that
we were met with at the beginning of the
call
generic you called the generic mail
correct correct
now you also testified a little earlier
that this was a very nice
series of penthouses right
yes
did you interview
uh
the woman that was sitting with amber
heard
i attempted to their all parties were
uncooperative
what what did you say to the woman that
was with miss miss hurt
i don't recall the exact word but i
introduced myself to everyone and asked
if they seen what happened or know what
happened
and they all refused to speak to me
did you ask for their names
i recall yes i did ask them names nobody
would give me
their names
that's a little unusual isn't it
no it's not
a lot of people don't like us
well is it that they don't like you or
is it
potentially that they
don't want to
with a domestic violence situation are
reluctant to press charges
every situation is different
based on my training experience where i
work it's usually that people do not
like us
do you have a
recollection of what the woman who was
with amber heard looks like
no recollection
do you know what color hair she had
i have zero recollection
so you don't recall how old she was how
tall she was what her hairstyle was how
tall she was sitting down
zero recollection
but somehow you're sure you tried to
interview her and she refused to answer
questions yes it's common practice i i
try to interview everyone
during my investigation
so did you pull out your notebook at any
time while you were in the penthouse
i did not i had nothing to write no one
would speak to me
well how did you know that when you
started asking the questions that they
weren't going to give an answer
because they just looked at me
but wouldn't you pull out your notebook
first oh give me a break then write down
the answers as they're giving them to
you no i don't put anything in my hands
for officer safety issues until i'm sure
that i have something to say
i'm sorry officer can you repeat your
answer
[Music]
i don't put anything in my hands for
officer safety reasons
if i'm not sure i'm gonna write
i keep my hands free
when i ask the questions i got no
answers therefore i didn't
take out any notebooks or pens
pretty sensible did you have any reason
to fear for your safety at the time that
you were talking with amber hurt and
woman with her she didn't know yet
i always fear for my safety a potential
suspect could have been in the house so
yes i
my guard was not down if that's what
you're asking
what did you do first did you look at
the throughout the house to ensure that
the person wasn't there or did you ask
the questions first and then look at the
house
are you tempted to ask questions first
i can't just go into a house and start
checking it without asking questions
so what questions did you ask first
i don't recall specific questions
do you recall any of your questions
i don't well just the gist of the
interview right i mean you recall any of
the answers that you were given
i don't recall
now we went through the domestic
violence supplemental report and some of
the guidelines for officers on domestic
violence do you recall that the crime
scene a number of the items
reflected location ransacked location
vandalized furniture and disarray
personal property damage do you remember
those being
items as the checklist for prop for
crime scene for domestic violence
as they pertain to domestic violence
reports yes i do
right
now
you
did you ever speak with the two officers
who answered the second call for the
townhouse that night
i did not
did you ever communicate in any manner
with the two officers who answered the
second call to the penthouse
i did not
did you communicate through a third
party to the second set of officers
relating to the domestic violence call
and your determination
i did not
did you know the two officers
who will respond to the second poll
do you know who they are to this day
i do not
have you ever spoken to the other two
officers
about
uh about the responding to this call on
may 21 2016.
i have not
have you ever spoken with anyone else
about
your response and their response to this
call on may 21st 2016.
i am not
and just so everybody is aware up until
now you've been listening to question
from questioning from ms heard's counsel
at this point i believe we're going to
shift over to questioning from mr depp's
council
i want you to focus on
the date of the incident that we've been
talking about during this deposition
and that is uh may 21st 2016.
i'll refer to that as the date of the
incident
um do you understand what i mean when i
say due to the incident
yes i do
okay
so as of the date of the incident
or how long had had you
been a training officer
since
i believe the end of november
of 2015.
so between six to eight months
yes prior to the date of the incident
for how long had you been a training
officer
[Music]
uh four to six months
okay
and as of the date of the incident
approximately how many
um
incidents of domestic violence
had you
come across i can't tell you i've
i mean i believe they said hundreds
yes that's how i understood it from uh
testimony i read in previous depositions
of these
so it's in the
hundreds yes
okay
now
when you uh
and you indicated that
[Music]
you proceeded to the incident um at the
eastern columbia building
due to
what you
heard from dispatch is that correct
correct
and you recall as you sit here today uh
what you were told from dispatch that
led you into the eastern columbia
building on the date of the incident
i don't have an independent recollection
okay
as you see here today you recall that it
had something to do
[Music]
with a dispute at that location
okay
and when you first
arrived at the scene of the incident
what did you first do on entering the
building
[Music]
we met with a security guard in the
lobby
who
escorted us to the elevator
did you ask that security guard any
questions about
the building
strike that suggest that security guard
any questions
not that i recall
did the security guard escort you up to
the penthouse
they
gave us access through the elevator i do
not believe that
they came up to the penthouse with us i
believe they just access elevator
okay
and when you arrived at the uh penthouse
and exited the elevator was it just you
and your partner mr haddon
officer hadn't
yes
and what did you do next
we tried to listen for
any kind of sounds
of domestic violence
we
checked the hallways we didn't observe
anyone
we went out to a courtyard didn't
observe anyone
and
based on what i was just reminded of
there was a woman in the gym who didn't
seem involved
was working out looked fine nothing out
of the ordinary
and then we responded
to a door in the hallway and
i knocked and was met by a male
okay
up until that point in time from exiting
the elevator to knocking on that door
did you see anything that indicated
a crime i did not
open to the point where you knocked on
that door
um
did you see any see or hear or witness
anything indicating that there had been
a domestic violence perpetrated i did
not
up until you knocked on that door did
you see anything
which you would have considered out of
the ordinary
i did not
and i guess what i'm asking is
walking from
the
elevator
to the gym
and then to
the door that you knocked on
yes i was in the hallway
okay and during that time period from
accident elevator through to knocking on
the door
um was there anything in the hallway
that was unusual to you not that i
observed now
did you see any uh
stains on the floor
not that i recall
did you see any uh vandalism in that
area
no i did not
did you see uh any
broken glass in that area
i did not
okay
and upon knocking on the door what
happened next
[Music]
hey
may i open the door
i don't remember the exact
questions and conversation we had but
i remember asking
if they called for help and
he said that
it was the neighbor
and that she was inside of his house
apartment
with
his girlfriend
and i asked him if they could step out
and he told me
to wait and he shut the door
and we waited
uh we waited for them to exit
i don't remember how much time passed by
and they came out and that's where i met
with his girlfriend and who i know now
is misheard
uh in the hallway
and up until that point in time
did you hear anything that led you to
believe
that a crime had been committed i did
up until not point in time did you see
anything that made you believe that a
crime had been committed i did not
up until that point in time did you hear
anything that made you believe that
there had been an act of domestic
violence there i did not
open to that point in time did you see
anything that made you believe that
there had been an act of domestic
violence there
i did not
okay
so you indicated that um
after you knocked on the door uh you
spoke with
and
you spoke with the gentleman is that
correct
okay
and you previously testified to uh
someone as a generic white male is that
the same person
yes
so your previous testimony when you were
referring to the generic white male
that's the person who who opened the
door when you first knocked on a crack
yes there was only one male at the
location besides my partner
and there was only one note and if
that's where the entire time you're at
the location yeah so in the hall
you've met with a generic white male
miss heard and the generic white male
boyfriend is that right
it was just those three folks
[Music]
and you were there with uh your partner
officer had
and
how
in the hallway how far were you standing
from this herd
it was closed probably
like
two to five feet
okay
and at that time
did you
notice any injuries on this herd i did
not
okay
were you looking to see if she had any
injuries at that time yes i was
and
um
so you were looking to see if miss hurd
had any injuries and
he determined that she did not is that
accurate
correct
and was the lighting
good enough in the hallway for you to
make that determination yes the hallways
was well lit
and at the time were you wearing any
sort of corrected lenses i was not
all right
although you are not wearing corrective
lenses were you prescribed corrective
lenses at the time
no i have never worn
glasses and i'm not prescribed i have
good vision
[Music]
and at that time did you have good
vision
yes at the time you were
observing misheard
did you have good vision
yes i did
and did you observe any injuries at that
time i did
not what did you
ask and just heard at that time if
anything
i don't
have a independent recollection again
it's been so long i
i don't remember specific questions
okay
now let me just back up a little bit um
during the time period when you left the
elevator
and
when ms heard came onto the hallway
at any time did the generic white
male
tell you that there had been an act of
domestic violence no he did not
didn't tell you anything that made you
think there may have may have been an
act of domestic violence
no he did not
did he tell you anything that made you
believe that that
a crime may have been committed no he
did not
and during that time period did you ask
him um
what had happened or what was happening
yes i did ask him
he just
refused to give me any information
okay so now
fast forward to what we were talking
about with respect to
you in the hallway with the generic
white male miss herd and the generic
white male girlfriend
after we observed her and saw no sign of
injury what did you do next
i advised her that
[Music]
we would be conducting a protective
suite just to make sure that there was
no one else in the house
and
she agreed
if her neighbor the male
could accompany us with the protective
suite
okay
up until that point in time
uh did you ask and has heard what
happened
yes i did
and what was her response
no response she was uncooperative and an
officer signed at that time was mr
cooperative
mr was uncooperative
thank you
and by uncooperative does that mean that
when you asked her a question she
wouldn't say a word
she said something that made you think
she was not cooperating she wouldn't say
anything
okay
but just to be clear you would ask
questions and she wouldn't say anything
right
and what did you do at that point
[Music]
after the protective sweep
i asked her
again
if she wanted to talk to me if anything
happened
again i don't remember the specific
questions that i asked her
but i asked her questions to establish
if there was some sort of
crime
who was involved and again she wouldn't
give me any information i asked i
attempted to ask her friend
the other woman in the room
i even
asked the males to wait in the hallway
so we could just be us women in there so
we could talk privately maybe she felt
more comfortable that way
still they denied that there was any
crime
they wouldn't answer
any specific questions
so i wrote a business card i advised her
she changed her mind that she could call
us at any time and we would respond to
help her out
so backing up a bit to
the time you're in the hallway with the
three of them
and you testified that
this herd was uncooperative
um and then
you indicated you did
a sweep
i want to start with from the point of
time in the hallway where she was
uncooperative
transitioning to the sweep
how did that occur did you
ask her if you could look at in the
penthouses how did this how did you go
from standing in the hallway to
conducting a suite
i
i don't recall
you know before you
before you swept the
penthouses
um did you ask if you could enter the
penthouses yes i did
okay and who
was the response
i
i can't remember if she gave me a
response or nodded her ahead i i can't
remember from what you observed or heard
from this heard
you took it that she was permitting you
to enter the penthouses and look around
is that accurate
okay
okay
um was it more than one penthouse
there was yes there was two
okay and this turned sweep we've been
using is that a technical police officer
term
what do you mean by conducting a sleep
it's called a protective sweep and we do
so to make sure that
there's no other individuals that may be
victims that are hurt inside of the
location
or suspects
hiding concealing themselves from
officers
uh that would attack the victim after we
left the location so we go in to verify
that any potential
suspects are gone from the location for
the victim safety
thank you and you conducted a protective
sweep of two penthouses correct
correct what was your understanding of
who owned or lived in the first
penthouse that you performed a
protective sweep on
it was my understanding that
amber heard
that it was her home
again the
gentleman
directed us that's why he came with us
so we wouldn't get lost
i see
and during your protective sweep during
the first time of the first penthouse
um
did anybody accompany you during the
entire sleep
yes the male the only male that was
there besides my partner
[Music]
okay and your partner conducted this
week with you
correct
okay
and
as to the protective sweep of the first
penthouse did you
go into every room of the penthouse
to my knowledge yes
and was your knowledge based on
the generic white male leading you
around
right was it your understanding
that you
did your protective sleep um included
you looking in every room in the
penthouse
right
during the protective sweep of the first
penthouse
did you
see anything
that
led you to believe that a crime had been
committed
i did not
during the protective belief of the
first penthouse did you hear anything
that made you think the crime had been
committed
i did not
during the first protective sweep did
you see anything that made you think
that an act of domestic violence had
occurred
i did not
during the protective sleep of the first
penthouse did you
hear or see anything
i'm sorry did you
see anything that made you believe an
act of domestic violence had occurred
i did not
okay
upon your completion of
the sweep protective sweep of the first
penthouse
up until that point in time
from
you exiting the elevator up into that
point of time did you hear or see
anything that made you believe that a
crime had been committed i did not
[Music]
open to that point of time did you
hear or see anything that made you think
an act of domestic violence had occurred
i did not
no i want to ask you
you testified that
you testified to you
viewing
misheard
and not seeing any signs of injury
did you
view her again after that
first dealing
during the interviews and throughout the
entire investigation i'm constantly
scanning her and watching so i if i see
any other observations that would
indicate any injury or domestic violence
and did you see anything like that
and you didn't see
did you see anything like that during
the entire series
entire time period
you were on that call
and
do you believe that you
had enough time
viewing this herd to determine whether
or not
she had sustained any injuries
yes i do
can you deter and did he determine that
she sustained any injuries
i determined that she did not sustain
any injuries
so other than the conversation you had
with her in the hallway when you first
got there did you have any other
conversations with this herd
i did
inside of the inside of the lost or
penthouse sorry
okay was that before or after the
protective sleep sweep
i believe both before and after
i attempted
okay how many conversations separate
conversations did you have with mr
i don't recall
okay
there was at least the one in the
hallway
and there was one
before or after the protective suit
correct
i'm sorry let's try to answer
correct
okay
and
during the second conversation you had
with her after the one in the hallway
how close were you to her
the same
two to five feet she was right in front
of me
were you close enough to get a good view
to determine whether or not she had any
injuries
yes i was
okay
and during that second conversation did
you determine
whether or not she had an injury
i determined that she did not have any
injuries
at any point in time during the incident
during the date of the incident
uh did she complain of any injury
she did not
during the protective sweep of the
penthouse
did you see anything
in disarray
i did not
okay
now you indicated let me ask you did you
do a protective sweep of the second
compound
yes i did
did the generic white male accompanying
you accompany you on that sweep as well
yes he did
[Music]
what was your understanding of who owned
or resided in that second penthouse
i had no idea
okay
[Music]
did you
during that second protective sweep
did you walk through every room in that
penthouse
from my understanding yes we did
okay
and during that second protective sleep
did you see anything that you would say
was in disarray
i did not
during that second protected sweep did
you see anything
that made you believe there had been a
crime committed
i did not
during that second protective sweep did
you hear anything that made you think a
crime had been committed i did not
during your protective sweep of the
second penthouse
did you see anything that made you
believe an act of domestic violence had
occurred i did not
during the protective sweep of the
second
second penthouse
did you hear or say anything
that made you believe
a crime had been committed
i did not
after you performed the second
protective i'm sorry after you performed
the protective sweep sweep of the second
penthouse what did you do
re-responded to where amber heard was
and i again tried to
see if i could get any information from
her
i was unsuccessful and then i issued her
the business card
and let her know that she could call us
back if she wanted to talk
did she answer any of your questions
no she did not
at any point in time during the entirety
of the incident did ms heard answer any
of your questions no she did not
during the entire time of the incident
did miss her complain of any injury
no she did not
during the entirety of your time at the
incident
did
anybody say anything that made you
believe a crime had been committed
no they did not
during the entirety of the time you were
at the incident did anybody say anything
that made you believe an active
act of domestic violence had occurred
no they did not
during the entirety of your time at the
incident did you see anything that made
you believe a crime had occurred
i did not
during it during the entirety of your
time at the incident did you hear
anything that made you believe a crime
had been committed
i did not
during the entirety of your time at the
incident did you hear or see anything
that made you believe an act of an act
of domestic violence had occurred i did
not
had you heard of
anybody by the name of ms hurd at that
time
never
neighborhood
no i have never heard of amber heard
before that time okay
[Music]
pretty groundbreaking stuff
did you recognize any of the people that
you encountered during the incident i
did not
pretty riveting
at the time of the internet did you have
any reason to believe
that
anybody you encountered at the incident
was famous
i did not
okay
and during the entire time
you're at the penthouses during the
incident
um
did you have any reason to believe that
mr depp was affiliated uh are involved
in the incident
i did not
i'm not a reporter can you
repeat my last question i lost where it
was
during the entire time you were at the
penthouses during the incident did you
witness any bruises on this herd
and there was not a response
it did not observe any injuries on this
earth
okay
did you observe any swelling on
the third state
i did not
did you observe anything
that led you to believe
that she was a victim of domestic
violence
i did not alex if you can pull up uh
exhibit two
yes
having your having your deposition taken
on july 18 2016 in connection with
mr death and miss herd
yes
okay
um
you recall
getting testimony in connection with
that deposition
is it yes i'm sorry officer yes
okay
and
did you give
accurate and true testimony at that time
yes
okay
and you understood you were under all
correct
okay
alex if you can go to page 26
officer signs do you recall testifying
as to
um
who called testifying that
and i'm talking about today
he recalled just testifying that
you
can't recall what
this word said to you if anything i do
not have an independent recollection but
i can
go off what i'm seeing here on my screen
okay
uh your honor we're at five o'clock it
looks like we have about uh 18 minutes
left do you want to you don't have any
problem finishing it tonight dude let's
go and finish it okay thank you
wow
and you agree with me that your memory
of the
day
of the incident
was fresher
on july 18 2016 than it is today
yes that is correct
okay
and the incident was may 21 2016.
this deposition was taken july 18 2016.
how long after the incident was this
deposition taken
uh
i think they should start it over yeah
just fuzzy audio
if i could have control
[Music]
it's riveting stuff
a little delayed alexa that cannot be
pictured that just the way it is
uh this is alex speaking
uh yeah i'm afraid i can't uh help that
i'm sorry mr president
that's fine
officer science i'm gonna start here do
you see my cursor
yes i do
okay i'm gonna start here at line three
the question is
okay but we'll get back to that
before you did a a sweep
for a check of the rest of
the penthouse
did you have an opportunity to speak
with ms heard when you were in the
apartment answer yes i did
okay question okay can you tell us
about
that conversation
answer sure i asked her what happened
opening question she said nothing and
she continued to cry i said
who do you live with who do you live
here with she shook her head as if she
did not want to answer
i asked her are you hurt
do you need an
ambulance and she shook her head again
no
at that point i asked her if she mine if
she would mind if i checked her
apartment and that's when she said no
officer does this refresh your
recollection of the conversation you had
with ms hurt at that time yes it is
and your testimony that i just read is
that true and accurate
yes it is during the entire time period
you were at the penthouses
on may 21st 2016.
did mitch heard say that she had been
assaulted in any way by anybody
no she did not
[Music]
the food is here
pretty explosive allegations
whoa easy everybody
did someone in chat generate that sound
during
your protective sweep of the two
penthouses
did you view anything that you would
characterize as vandalism
i did not
[Music]
i don't know how much we learned from
this
could we ask them for 2x that would be
interesting
during the entire time you were at the
penthouses on may 21st 2016
were you looking for any probable cause
to believe
that a crime had been committed
yes it was
and where did you determine
i determined there was no crime
did you what did you determine with
respect to an assessment of probable
cause
there was no probable cause of any sort
of crime
thank you
[Music]
is this a redirect now
[Music]
[Music]
pizza is here oh thank god
[Music]
hmm
during the entire time
you were at
the penthouse on may 21st 2016
were you wearing
any body worn
video cameras i was not
are you certain of that
i am certain
and how are you how is it that you are
certain of that
because i didn't start using body worn
video until
june of 2016.
[Music]
and that's after
uh the date of the incident correct
correct
alex if you wouldn't mind putting
exhibit 9 back up
officer science you were shown this
document earlier what is
it is a domestic violence supplemental
report
and do you recall uh council asked you
about the victim column and the crime
scene column
yes i do
um do recall
also see that there's a suspect column
in the middle
yes
okay
and is there any difference between a
victim column and a suspect column with
respect to
uh
the terms and the terms
of box terms
no difference
[Music]
did you fill out one of these forms in
connection with your investigation on
may 21st 2016
i did not
why not
because it was determined there was no
crime
and officer signs just uh one more
question with respect to that exhibit
nine i know it's not up
but
the fact that you did not fill out that
form um
consistent with your training yes it is
i wouldn't fill that out because
there was no crime it doesn't
it's not called for it
when you testified during the london
trial
at the time did you believe your
testimony was accurate
yes i do
[Music]
at all times you've testified
[Music]
under
in any legal proceedings trials
depositions
uh
do you always give accurate and truthful
testimony yes i do
and do you have any reason to not give
accurate and truthful testimony
in connection with about this deposition
i do not
officer sign do you see these two
pictures
yes i do
um do you recognize the person in the
picture
yes amber heard
in both pictures
yes
because you see a difference in these
two between these two pictures
yes i i do the lighting
of the photos
do you see any difference in connection
with
[Music]
the redness on the cheeks of this herd
as between these two pictures
yes i do the
the left side is
the photo's brighter
okay
and other than that would you agree with
me that
these two pictures
are the same in other words
this hurts face uh
the position of her face
everything about
her in these pictures is
identical except for the differences
that you've indicated
yes
okay
and even though these are the same
pictures do you see any difference with
respect to
the redness
in
on this herd's face with respect to the
two pictures yes the photo on the left
is brighter causing the redness on the
cheeks to
what appears to be brighter or
exaggerated
what does it say
with respect to
this concentrate on fish on the left
can you read for me what it says in the
little box
at the very top on the left
under add a title do you see a date and
a timestamp
[Music]
yes i see it
what's it say
date and time stamp
date is may 21st 2016.
timestamp is 9 25 12
p.m
[Music]
and now let's look at the other picture
exhibit 29 at the same spot can you read
for me that what the time stamp says
there
yes it says uh may 21st 2016 9 25 12 pm
so both
exhibits both pictures are the same
exact time stamp correct
and even though that's the case you
still believe
that
there's a difference between
the two pictures as you previously
described i said you
three signs do you see that at 41.
yes
you recall council asking a question
yes
during your
uh protective sweep of
the two penthouses on may 21st 2016
did you see anything in
disarray now
it's all very suspicious officer uh
signs um
for how long have you been a
la
los angeles police officer
i will be going on 12 years
officer science uh
in connection with your investigation uh
at the
eastern columbia building on may 21st
2016.
uh were you
in a rush in any way
[Music]
were you willing to stay as long as
necessary to determine if a crime had
been committed yes
[Music]
at any point in time
during your investigation on may 21st
2016 at the penthouses did this herd ask
you to appeal the report
no
did anybody uh
that you spoke with or saw
on may 21st 2016
at the penthouses ask you to follow the
court no
did you have any cause
i could file a report
no
and was that determination in line with
your training yes
[Music]
interesting
if you had witnessed anything
that led you to believe that an act of
domestic violence had occurred would you
have filed a report
yes
and you in fact did not follow the
report correct yes
[Music]
and
if you had witnessed something
that led you to believe that an act of
domestic violence had occurred
would you have followed the report even
if miss heard had asked you not to
yes
and is that is that in line with your
training
yes
science you were asked some questions
and just so everybody's on the same page
we have about a minute and a half of
questions from mrs council at this point
when you
were
got off the elevator in the penthouse
and when you got on and how much time
you spent at the penthouse level i
approached it in my earlier but based on
the cross-examination i feel like we
need to go back
to that
so i'm going to ask you to take a look
at what is exhibit number six
and you recognize
you and officer hadden in this picture
yes
okay and
what time does the time stamp on this
uh picture
say for the elevator
it says 2104-43
okay that's 904 43 would that be right
p.m
yes and we looked at this earlier i'm
going to ask you to take a look at it
again at 21 and
so this one has what time
21
1949. all right and allowing ford
and officer science you said earlier
that you weren't sure whether there were
accuracies or inaccuracies in terms of
the elevators
but allowing for that there may be any
issues at all would you agree that it
still means that you were on and off
that elevator in 15 minutes
assuming the times are correct yes
okay you asked uh to look at a number of
the pictures that i had shown you
earlier that were taken on the night of
may
21st
2016
both before during and after the time
that you and officer hadden had reported
to
the uh
to ms heard's uh penthouse
do you recall seeing those again and
being asked about them
yes you were asked uh by
council for mr depp to take a look at
those again correct
all right
okay
and he asked you if you had seen any of
those photographs before and you
indicated that you had not correct
correct
so
other than what was placed in the cad
summary by either you or officer hadden
and then also went into the incident
recall
you are you aware of any documentation
that either you or officer hadden
collected
relating in any manner to your visit to
the penthouse on may 21
2016.
no
all right thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen that
concludes uh the testimony for today
please do not do any outside research
absolutely scintillating explosive
testimony
there as you can uh i i'm just rocking
the courtroom visibly
just a turn of events no one expected
still have some outstanding exhibits so
if you could get with jamie and see what
wins those are so we can get that taken
care of so we don't get backwards and we
keep keep up all right all right we'll
see you in the morning all right
so that's going to conclude today's
testimony i really appreciate everybody
who joined me uh kevin gouldy jeff quinn
and adam chismar
all grabbing memberships during
really an hour and 47 minutes of video
testimony that i don't think any of us
will ever forget
it's uh really just every second burned
into my mind
we will see how this resumes tomorrow
and of course as our coverage of the
2022 midterm elections
continues
we want to cover uh various debates and
things that are taking place so always
feel free to email info at
davidpakman.com if there are upcoming
2022 debates or different things that we
should be covering
always wanting to do that thanks also to
catty catty ah
carry catty ah
for the twitch prime subscription and of
course we wish our friend
hassan [ __ ] the fastest and safest
possible recovery from the virus see
everybody tomorrow